[Music]
each one of us sends 64 tonnes of waste
to the landfill during our lives that's
nearly four of these trucks filled to
the brim and there are more than 300
million of us which means that together
every year we generate 246 million tons
of waste
we throw something away and as far as
we're concerned that's the end of it but
it's not really the end at all for
example as a nation we throw away sixty
million plastic bottles every day that
means that every second we throw at 694
plastic bottles we also toss out 11
million tons of glass bottles and jars
every year that's the same weight as 440
titanic's or 30 Empire State building's
[Music]
most of our food has to be delivered as
cleanly and conveniently as possible we
like everything nicely washed packed and
especially wrapped from cereal and pizza
to meat and fish
we insist our food be untouched by human
hands as we tear our way through
mountains of packaging much of it is
plastic
to make it easier to carry our packages
home we slip them into another plastic
bag
then when we've unpacked our groceries
we throw all that packaging away in yet
another plastic bag in the trash can
over a lifetime we'll each throw away
enough of it to fill up one of those
trucks that's twenty nine thousand seven
hundred pounds
fifteen
all topped out by each and every one of
us it's not just plastic wrappers that
we throw away we also toss a huge amount
of aluminum into the trash and most of
it is soda cans and we dispose of 100
million aluminum and steel cans every
day enough to build a roof over all of
New York City
that's 36 billion cans tossed every year